Read John 17:2.
Okay? John 17:2 one more time because I
want to finish this with a bang.
That he the son should give eternal life
to as many as thou has given him. Now
pay attention to this because we're
going to go to a parallel to this
statement. I'm going to show you a
parallel to this statement. Let's go to
John 10 27-28.
John 10:27-28.
My sheep hear my voice and I know them
and they follow me. Jesus speaking. He
says they're my sheep. They hear my
voice. They know me and they follow me.
I know them and they follow me. Now pay
attention. And I I Jesus give unto them
eternal life and they shall never
perish. Neither shall any man pluck them
out of my hand. Guys, pay attention.
Jesus says they're my sheep. They hear
my voice. I give them eternal life.
Again, he says that like he did in John
17:2. No one can pluck them, deliver
them out of my hand. If they're in my
hand, they're the sheep in my hand. The
sheep in my hand, guys. Pay attention.
The sheep in my hand. And if they're in
my hand and they're my sheep, they can
never perish because there's no power to
pluck them out of my hand because I
guarantee their eternal preservation.
Right? My sheep, my voice, my sheep in
my hand. No one can take them out of my
hand. I give them eternal life. Right?
This what Jesus just said. My sheep, my
voice, sheep in my hand. I preserve
them. I care for them. No one can
deliver them out of my hand. I give them
eternal life. Correct? Okay. Now, let's
see what Jesus just did. Psalm 95 6-8.
Psalm 95 6 to8. Pay attention growing
everyone else. My sheep, sheep in my
hand, hear my voice. My sheep, sheep in
my hand, hear my voice. Psalm 956 to8.
Let's see if you catch it. Oh, come, let
us worship and bow down. Let us kneel
before Jehovah our maker. For he is our
God. We are the people of his pasture,
the sheep of his hand. Today, if you
will hear his voice. No, I don't think
you caught it.
We are the sheep of Jehovah's hands. We
are to hear his voice.
Jesus said, "There are my sheep, the
sheep in my hand. Do you hear my voice?
Who caught it?
Do me a favor now. Protestant believer,
post John 10:27:28
with Psalm 95 6-7 back to back.
No, not John Riaz. Jesus applied the
psalm to himself. It's Jesus speaking.
Okay, let's read it one more time. My
sheep hear my voice and I know them and
they follow me. I give unto them eternal
life and they shall never perish.
Neither shall any man pluck them out of
my hand. Sheep in my hand, my hand.
Eternal life I give them. My sheep hear
my voice. Now Psalm 95. Oh come, let us
worship and bow down. Let us kneel
before Jehovah our maker. For he is our
God. We are the people of his pasture,
the sheep of his hand. today if you will
hear his voice.
The psalmist says, you don't need to
post verse eight. Protestant,
I know you're excited. You posted seven
twice in a row. And then verse eight.
The psalmist says, "We are the sheep in
Jehovah's hand, and we are here to hear
Jehovah's voice." Jesus says, "They're
my sheep in my hand. They hear my voice.
Thank you. Protestant Protestant loves
us so much he gives us bonus verses.
Did it sink in
or no?
And then Jesus says what? I give them
eternal life and no one can pluck them
out of my hand. Right? John 10:28 one
more time.
John 10:28 one more time.
and I give unto them eternal life, and
they shall never perish, neither shall
any man pluck them out of my hand. Now,
compare what you just read with
Deuteronomy 32:39.
I give them eternal life. No one can
pluck them out of my hand. Deuteronomy
32:39, guys, pay attention. Pay
attention. Jesus says, "I give them
eternal life. No one can pluck them out
of my hand." Deuteronomy 32:39. Pay
attention.
See now that I, even I am he, and there
is no God with me. I kill, I make alive.
I wound and I heal. Neither is there
anyone that can deliver out of my hand.
Whoa. I make alive. Jesus. I give
eternal life. No one can deliver out of
my hand. Jesus. No one can pluck them
out of my hand. Whoa.
Wow.
Feeling
feeling.
Oh, but now 29 and 30. John 10:29 and
30. Watch here.
John 10:29:30. Now notice what he says.
My father which gave them me is greater
than all and no man is able to pluck
them out of my father's hand. I and my
father are one. Wow. Notice no one can
pluck them out of my hand. No one can
pluck them out of my father's hand. Why?
Because we are one. But you know what's
beautiful? Do you see that verb are? You
Greek speakers can confirm. I and my
father are one. Let me show you what the
Greek is. Here you go. Thank the Lord
for modern technology.
Okay, here it is. Let me get you the
link.
Modern technology.
[Music]
Go there. Click on the link. It says ego
hen. You see that word esman? It's
plural. Plural. It's a plural verb. And
it's literally I and my father, we are
one.
Esman is plural. It's we are. Showing
that Jesus is not the father. The father
is not the son. And he says we are one.
So you see the context guys, pay
attention. Jesus says, "They're my sheep
in my hand. The sheep of my hand. They
hear my voice. I give them eternal life.
No one can pluck them out of my hand. No
one can pluck them out of my father's
hand." You know why? Because the father
and I, we are one. One in what sense?
We're not one person. We're one in our
ability and power to preserve all
believers forever, guaranteeing they
will never perish. Jesus saying that
he's one with the father in power, in
divine power.
Okay. Now, let's see the response of the
Jews. John 10:31-33.
We're almost done. Lord willing, in the
next session, I'll address some
objections.
John 10:31-33.
Yep. The trying God is amazing.
Then the Jews took up stones again to
stone him. And Jesus answered them,
"Many good works have I showed you from
my father. For which of those works do
you stone me?" Now notice what the Jews
say in 33.
Notice what they say in 33.
The Jews answered him, saying, "For a
good work we stone thee not, but for
blasphemy, and because that thou being a
man makest thyself God." See, they
understood the language of Jesus. They
knew the Old Testament. You're a man, a
flesh and blood Jew, a man, but you're
speaking as if you're God because you
just claim the things that the Old
Testament ascribes to God. The Old
Testament says God makes alive. No one
can deliver out of his hand. You said,
you said you give eternal life, no one
can pluck out of your hand. Old
Testament says we are the sheep in
Jehovah's hand. We are his sheep to hear
his voice. You're saying that believers
are your sheep in your hand. You
preserve them.
So, you're not the father and you are a
man and claim to be God. We know the
father is God and we know a man can't be
God and you're not the father and you're
a man and yet you claim to be God.
You get it?
Now, question folks,
since the father is the only true God,
pay attention now, Riaz and everyone
else. Since the father is the only true
God and Jesus the son says, "I am one
with the father in his power and ability
to preserve all believers incorruptible
to guarantee that no believer will ever
perish and be destroyed. I'm one with
him in that ability, in that power to
guarantee the eternal preservation of
all believers."
Then Jesus just claimed to be one in
essence with the only true God. Since
the father is the only true God and
Jesus is one with the father in essence
in his divine ability and power. That
means Jesus is essentially one with the
only true God. He's one in essence with
the only true God because he's one in
essence with the father and the father
is the only true God. And since there
can't be a second true God, that means
in context, if Jesus is one with the
father in power, making him one with the
father in essence, then that means Jesus
is one in essence with the only true
God. And since there can't be a second
true God, he too must be the only true
God.
Thank you, Alex. Do you see why the
early church was forced to the doctrine
of the trinity?
You got it. Now
you see why Riaz going to verse five.
You're not making the best case
possible. You're actually
allowing the Muslims to get away with
murder. and you're not making the best
case possible
by just going to verse 5 and ignoring
verses 1 and two and then showing the
relationship of John 17 17 verse2 with
John 10:27-33.
You see what I did? I took John 17:2
where Jesus says the son gives eternal
life to all that the father gives him
and then took it back to John 10:27-30.
The objection is from John 17. Make sure
you answer the objection from the book
that they're misquing before you go to
another book.
You got it now.